[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem freitag die vom sport hat man hat
jemand ein schöner sonntag von mir und
wir haben unter anderem diese themen für
sie
paukenschlag in berlin af geschäftsleute
verlässt die partei und spricht von
totalitären anklängen
juwelenraub aus dem grünen gewölbe in
dresden stehen sechs mutmaßliche täter
vor gericht
und ende einer ära sportdirektor max
eberl verlässt borussia mönchengladbach
aus gesundheitlichen gründen
seit jahren schon tobt in der afg spitze
der machtkampf zwischen parteichef
mountain und dem extrem rechten
parteiflügels verhältnis zu seinem
co-vorsitzenden copala und
fraktionschefin weide gilt als zerrüttet
jetzt schmeißt er hin nicht nur den
parteivorsitz er verlässt die afg und
erklärt teile der partei stünden nicht
auf dem boden der freiheitlich
demokratischen grundordnung nicole
diekmann eine ganz normale
bundesvorstandssitzung sollte es sein
heute nachmittag doch als der parteichef
an kommt ist klar es herrscht
ausnahmezustand sein co-vorsitzender hat
hingeschmissen und alle überrascht
erster verhaltene reaktion nach einer
schnellen krisensitzung
ich denke die letzten tage und wochen
haben auch gezeigt dass sie direkt doch
ein stück weit von der partei entfernt
hat und auch dass auch die partei nicht
mehr vollumfänglich hinter ihnen stand
leuten war zunehmend isoliert einst
schaffte er es noch rechtsaußen die
andreas kalbitz aus der partei zu
drängen zuletzt aber konnte er sich
nicht mal mehr in wichtigeren fragen
durchsetzen zum beispiel der ob sein
intimfeind max otte aus der cdu als afd
kandidat für das bundespräsidialamt ins
rennen geht
selbst der lange gemeinsame sache mit
den ultrarechten in seiner partei machte
nennt den rechtsruck der afg als grund
für seine entscheidung
ich habe immer versucht dieser partei
maß und mitte zu geben und hatte den
eindruck damit immer weniger
durchzudringen zuletzt gar nicht mehr
und wenn dieser punkt erreicht ist dann
ist es zeit zu gehen sein mandat im
eu-parlament will morgen jedoch behalten
dort droht ihm seit gestern die
aufhebung seiner immunität seine
spendenaffäre spitzt sich zu die
stellvertretende fdp chefin alice weide
vermutet dies als grund für mountains
manöver ich kann mir nicht vorstellen
dass der parteiaustritt läutens nicht in
einem zusammenhang mit der aufhebung
seiner immunität im europaparlament zu
tun hat dass er nun ideologische gründe
vorschiebt und die partei der er lange
vor gestanden ist mit schmutz bewirft
spricht nicht vom charakter sagte sie
dem zdf
allerdings kursierten schon seit tagen
das gerücht wollten könnte zurücktreten
womöglich will er dem verfassungsschutz
zuvorkommen der könnte im märz
entscheiden die afg komplett zu
beobachten nicht nur wie bisher in
teilen
ein krachender abgaben theo koll oder
das kann man wohl sagen wollten galt
jahr ist der kopf der weniger extremen
innerhalb der batterie und die hatten
eigentlich lange zeit die mehrheit in
der afc beispielsweise als leuten den
chefdenker der extrem rechten kallwitz
noch ausschließen lassen konnte aber das
ist eben lange vorbei zuletzt wurde
leuten die machtverschiebung und seine
eigene machtlosigkeit ja immer wieder
vor augen geführt er ist sogar damit
gescheitert ein afd abgeordneten der
sich selbst als das zitat freundliche
gesicht des nationalsozialismus
bezeichnet aus der partei ausschließen
zu lassen wobei zur vollständigkeit dazu
gehört dass man sich den extremen auch
lange gedient hat denn für ihn war die
partei ja immer auch ein macht wie er
wollte eigentlich einfluss und
politische relevanz für die partei und
für sich 9 hat lange geglaubt er könne
geschmeidig mit den wölfen tanzen aber
die haben ihn jetzt schlichtweg gebissen
dankeschön nach berlin tegel war das
ganz anders der abschied von den
parteivorsitzenden bei den grünen weil
annalena baerbock und robert habeck
jetzt minister ämter haben braucht die
partei eine neue führung die wird morgen
gewählt heute stand beim digitalen
parteitag noch mal das duo habeck
baerbock im rampenlicht aus berlin
patrick wiedemeyer
vier jahre lang haben annalena baerbock
und robert habeck einen ganz neuen
führungsstil bei den grünen geprägt vier
jahre lang haben sie es geschafft die
partei zu einen flügelkämpfe gab es erst
wieder bei der besetzung der
ministerposten vor einer halben stunde
dann der voraussichtlich letzte auftritt
als doppel an der parteispitze bei dem
beide kompromisse bei der
regierungsbildung als kunst der politik
verteidigen manche tun das ab und sagen
so jetzt machen aber die grünen
kompromisse bei kompromisse zum leben
dazugehören sowie das in unserem
wahlprogramm gemacht haben so wie wir
das alle in unserem leben machen das
beste für die menschen für die umwelt
für das klima rauszuholen das ist unsere
aufgabe
und wer das nicht sieht und wer das
glaubt durch abstrakte debatten abwehren
zu können der verkennt was die aufgabe
von politischen parteien ist sie haben
die grünen in die ampel regierung
geführt das jahr aber sie hinterlassen
auch probleme die pannen des wahlkampfs
zb sind bisher nicht aufgearbeitet
worden wir werden das auswerten und
schlüsse für die zukunft daraus ziehen
aber jetzt geht es natürlich darum die
projekte die wir uns vorgenommen haben
auch zu realisieren die partei ist
größer geworden die neuen mitglieder
müssen eingebunden werden das ist schon
wenn ich ohne da hat die der
parteivorstände menge zu tun und dann
muss man gucken wie man auf der einen
seite die regierungsverantwortung hat
andere sätze die auch guckt dass die
partei dabei sichtbar ist der übergang
findet ohne großes publikum statt fast
alle delegierten sind nur digital dabei
fakt ist es wird ein gewaltiger
personeller umbruch für die partei die
neue parteiführung die morgen gewählt
wird wird den ausgleich finden müssen
zwischen klimabewegung und regierungs
realität
matthias fornoff ist bei mir mit dem
neuen politbarometer guten abend jemand
matthäus noch nicht mal zwei monate sind
die grünen jetzt teil der neuen
bundesregierung wie kommt das
dreierbündnis an naja die ampel hätte
jedenfalls auch jetzt eine deutliche
mehrheit die grünen legen zu auch
annalena baerbock wird deutlich besser
bewertet olaf scholz verliert dagegen
stark wie auch die spd wenn am nächsten
sonntag bundestagswahl wäre bliebe die
spd mit 24 prozent knapp stärkste partei
- 3 cdu/csu 23 prozent plus 1 grüne 18
+2 fdp 10 -1 afd ebenfalls zehn linke 7
prozent plus 1
innerhalb der regierung können sich
grüne und fdp besser durchsetzen als die
spd so jedenfalls der eindruck der
befragten fast täglich berichten wir
über die drohende kriegsgefahr in europa
wie groß ist die sorge der menschen dass
russische truppen tatsächlich in die
ukraine einmarschieren meyer die sorge
die ist schon da eine mehrheit erwartet
das aber nicht russland wird in der
ukraine einmarschieren das sagen 36
prozent 57 prozent glauben das nicht der
ukraine waffen zu liefern fänden 20
prozent gut 73 prozent lehnen das ab
sollte deutschland gegenüber russland
mehr zugeständnisse machen das finden
nur 20 prozent
45 prozent würden sich noch weniger
zugeständnisse wünschen und 24 prozent
würden nicht viel ändern
etwas mehr als die hälfte der befragten
übrigens glaubt das russland uns weiter
zuverlässig gas liefern wird an dieser
stelle also vorsichtiger optimismus
immer wieder im griff von bankomat- ihr
das komplette politbarometer können sie
heute abend im heute journal um zehn
seen oder alle zahlen und daten schon
jetzt jederzeit unter zdf heute oder in
der zdf- heute- app
der
westen setzt in der ukraine krise weiter
auf diplomatie aussenministerin werburg
telefonierte mit ihrem russischen
kollegen lawrow und der französische
präsident makro am mittag mit russlands
präsident putin der forderte nochmals
verbindliche sicherheitsgarantien wie
bedrohlich die situation ist zeigt sich
auf einem schmalen landstreifen auf der
so genannten rabatt nehrung stehen sich
ukrainische soldaten und russische
einheiten von der besetzten krim
gegenüber anders heißt war dort
unterwegs in der militär zone auf der
rabatt nehrung seit 2014 seit der
annexion der krim ist der nur wenige
kilometer breiten küstenstreifen
zerteilt sollte russland eine offensive
starten dann könnte diese straße zu
einer wichtigen route für die russischen
panzer ins landesinnere der ukraine
werden die ukrainischen soldaten wissen
auch um die gefahr die vom meer aus
droht aber man hätte aus 2014 gelernt
sie seien bereit für den potentiellen
angriff aus der krim
ständig dass putin den verstand
beiden seiten
weiter auf der nehrung richtung
landesinnere
viele einwohner leben hier vom fischfang
doch seit der annexion seien sie im
täglichen kampf mit den russen um
fanggebiete erzählt uns valenta er sei
wütend und sollte es jetzt zum angriff
der russen kommen dann würden sie sich
rechnen wir haben grenzer reservisten
die sich gerade organisieren wir haben
auch waffen er hat ein jagdgewehr
ich habe eine granate wir werden unser
land die ukraine verteidigen und blüten
treffen
wir werden
so werden wir es ihm zeigen
[Gelächter]
vor der kamera patriotismus gegen die
kriegsangst nach dem interview sagt uns
oleg noch eigentlich wünsche er sich nur
frieden und keinen täglichen streit mehr
um die fanggebiete
zur corona lage die es nach ansicht des
gesundheitsministers trotz steigender
zahlen unter kontrolle die maßnahmen
zeigten wirkung sagt karl lauterbach
allerdings macht dem nach wie vor die
impflücken sorgen und mögliche engpässe
in den kliniken ein maßstab dafür ist
die hospitalisierung since it ends also
die krankenhauseinweisungen pro 100.000
einwohnern in einer woche wegen corona
der wert stieg in den letzten tagen
merklich und liegt jetzt bei 4,72
weniger berichtet das symbolbild für die
derzeitige misere an deres im zentrum
die quote immer noch zu gering der
gesundheitsminister ruft deshalb zur
impfung auf besonders appellierte an
menschen über 60 jahren wir haben dort
firma so viele ungeimpfte wie england
und dreimal so viele ungeimpfte wie
italien das heißt wir haben das
besondere sind die besondere situation
sehr viele ältere menschen und von
dieser besonders bedrohten gruppe sind
viele im vergleich zu anderen ländern um
geimpft daher müssen wir diese also
gruppe schütze in der vergangenen woche
haben sich hierzulande fast 900.000
menschen infiziert der höhepunkt von
omikron noch nicht erreicht wegen des
mangels an pcr tests wird die inzidenz
nicht mehr präzise erfasst der erkalten
chef voigt eine andere zahl in den focus
wir müssen jetzt in erster linie auf die
krankheitslast
und die krankheits schwere schauen denn
das ziel bleibt weiterhin schwere
verläufe zu verringern und die
arbeitsfähigkeit von kliniken aber
natürlich auch von anderen kritischen
infrastrukturen aufrecht zu halten genau
vor diesem stresstest für die kritische
infrastruktur warnen auch mediziner ich
glaube die nächsten wochen werden nicht
nur in den krankenhäusern hart werden
weil viel personal ausfällt und auch
viele kinder einfach zu hause betreut
werden müssen von eltern die in der
kritischen infrastruktur arbeiten selbst
wenn sie selbst nicht infiziert sind
spielraum für lockerungen sieht der
gesundheitsminister
deshalb noch nicht
und hier noch weitere corona zahlen das
rk ii registrierte mehr als
190.000 neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden
fast 50.000 mehr als vergangenen freitag
170 todesfälle kamen innerhalb eines
tages dazu die sieben tage incidents
stieg auf
1.073
der bundestag hat den bundeswehreinsatz
im irak um weitere neun monate
verlängert zu den aufgaben zählt die
ausbildung irakischer streitkräfte die
gegen die terror miliz islamischer staat
kämpfen die zahl der soldatinnen und
soldaten bleibt auch künftig auf 500
begrenzt im neuen mandat ist syrien als
mögliches einsatzgebiet auf wunsch der
grünen gestrichen worden
es war im november vor zwei jahren der
spektakuläre einbruch im grünen gewölbe
in dresden
diebe stahlen aus sachsens schatzkammer
kostbare juwelen
21 schmuckstücke mit insgesamt 4300
diamanten und brillanten ihr wert etwa
113 millionen euro von der beute fehlt
jede spur heute begann der prozess gegen
sechs männer mutmaßlich mitglieder eines
berliner platz aus dresden thomasberg
die torte das landgericht dresden ab
heute aufklären will ist beispiellos es
geht um den verbleib wertvollster
historischer schätze mutmaßlich
entwendet von sechs angeklagten die den
einbruch ins dresdner grüne gewölbe
akribisch geplant soll man soll eigens
zwei fahrzeuge angeschafft haben im
vorfeld soll bereits ein teil des
fenster geht das herausgesägt und dann
wieder mittels klebeband eingeführt
worden sein um am tag möglichst schnell
in das gebäude gelangen zu können zur
beute gehören diamant kollektionen teils
300 jahre alt ihr millionen wird liegt
in ihrer einzigartigkeit experten
vermuten genau deshalb eine
auftragsarbeit
ich kann mir gar nicht vorstellen dass
diese schmuckstücke ohne einen kunden
gestohlen wurden also einfach auf den
markt zu gehen und sie frei anzubieten
das geht natürlich überhaupt nicht man
will die schmuckstücke sofort erkennen
sofort ernsthafte hoffnungen auf
aussagen zum verbleib der schätze macht
sich kaum jemand zwei der angeklagten
haben vor fünf jahren die berühmte
goldmünze aus dem berliner bode museum
gestohlen die beiden verbüßen derzeit
dafür eine jugendstrafe von der münze
fehlt jede spur alle angeklagten
entstammen dem so genannten plan milieu
schwierig für ermittler da sind immer
gruppen den kaum mit zusammenarbeit
möglich ist die sich kaum den deutschen
strafverfolgungsbehörden öffnen die also
in einer parallelwelt weitgehend leben
also auch zahlreiche strukturiert sind
die verteidiger im saal äußerten heute
unisono zweifel an der beweislage 50
tage gibt sich das gericht zeit um
antworten zu finden auch auf die frage
ob es noch tippgeber gab vielleicht auch
im museum selbst
und jetzt noch was zum thema druck im
profifußball norbert gladbachs
langjähriger sportdirektor max eberl wir
hatten ja viele die sportliche talfahrt
der borussia mit angekreidet jetzt sein
rückzug er sei emotional erschöpft habe
keine kraft mehr erklärte er auf einer
wirklich bewegenden pressekonferenz ein
mutiger auf und ab tritt verbunden mit
systemkritik am hamsterrad fußball
es war seine schwierigste entscheidung
doch die eigene gesundheit geht vor max
eberl geht weil ich einfach erschöpft
bin weil ich einfach müde bin weil ich
keine kraft mehr habe diesen job
auszuüben fußball war sein leben die
borussia seine leidenschaft 23 jahre
lang diente er in verschiedenen
funktionen ein mensch der nicht mehr
kann zieht nun die reißleine und ich
beende was
ich beende was was mein leben war ebay
will das unbeschwerte lachen
wiederfinden trainer hütter muss ohne
ihn versuchen die mannschaft aus der
krise zu führen
das deutsche skisprung team hat im
ersten mixed wettbewerb des olympia
winters nur knapp das podest verpasst
beim heim weltcup in willingen landeten
die dsv-adler um skiflug weltmeister
karl geiger auf platz vier jubel beim
slowenischen mixteam ein siegburger
theissen der preo 20 sec und emma klinik
mit großem vorsprung die deutsche
mannschaft leid nach einer weite von 127
meter von katharina althaus im finale
noch auf platz zwei nach den sprüngen
von markus eisenbichler juliane seyfarth
und karl geiger blieb nur der undankbare
vierte platz
hab schon gemerkt dass der strom nicht
ganz optimal war und immer ein bisschen
schief rauskommen sagt bisschen
merkwürdig mit die letzte zeit jetzt
nicht passiert und das hat mich ziemlich
geärgert und speziellen teamspringen auf
platz zwei und villingen landete
norwegen vor dem gemischten team aus
österreich
zum tennis rafael nadal steht im finale
der australian open der spanier gewann
sein halbfinale gegen den italiener
matteo berät ihn in vier sätzen und
trifft im finale am sonntag auf den
russen daniil mit video sollte nadal
gewinnen wäre er mit 21 grand slam 7 der
erfolgreichste tennisprofi vorgeschichte
und hätte der roger federer und novak
djokovic die haben beide 20 mal die den
titel oder die titel hindert die titel
viele aufhören dankeschön eine
ausgewachsene sturm lage erwartet uns am
wochenende was das heißt erklärt gleich
erst intern im heute journal um 10
spricht christian sievers mit dem
bisherigen afg chef jörg das gesamte
heute team wünscht ihnen ein schönes
wochenende
[Musik]
eine gute ernte und herzlich willkommen
zum wetter am wochenende erwartet uns
eine ausgewachsene strom lage dieses
sturmtief hier erreicht uns bringt regen
und in den höheren lagen durchaus auch
schnee und dann dreht in der nacht auf
sonntag der wind auf nord bis nordwest
und dann kommt so richtig viel winter
auf an den küsten orkanböen und in den
höheren lagen im flachland sogar
orkanartige böen möglich schauen auf die
nacht und da gibt es schon viele wolken
im norden es regnet es nach süden teils
trocken im südosten ein paar
schneeflocken es wird klar zu teilweise
bei minus zwei bis minus 5 grad im
westen plus sechs grad und morgen im
tagesverlauf viele worten und regen in
den bergen auch schnee und im
tagesverlauf legt der wind weiter zu
teils sturm und schwere sturmböen und
vor allem in der nacht verschärft sich
die lage dann sind auch orkanartige böen
vor allem nach osten hin möglich und an
den küsten sowie in den bergen und das
bei temperaturen von drei grad an den
alpen und 12 grad im westen deutschlands
ziemlich wild für die jahreszeit am
sonntagvormittag immer noch teils
stürmisch und sturmböen im osten
deutschlands vor allem es können auch
noch orkanartige böen dabei sein bei
drei bis neun grad damit ein schöner
abend